remember when taylor lautner was just a  little pipsqueak of a canada it's  working keep it up jack boy well turns  out he almost dated another small star  in the making at the time check out what  Taylor and his scream queens co-star  John Stamos confessed to billboard  Britney tried to fix Taylor up with her  sister it was really cool  eg also caught up with the guys at the  iHeartRadio Festival in Las Vegas over  the weekend and they spilled some scream  queens secrets any steamy crazy sex  scenes there anything you yes I fig sex  scene coming up from next week right  soon yeah I got I got a little steamy  scene coming up with somebody  no [ __ ] was fun to film them so it's  with the hand